So what do we mean by dirty data?
Dirty data is data that contain
some kind of errors in them, or
are in a format that's unfriendly or
unusable.
You'll need to spend
time cleaning dirty data
to make sure you get a correct
answer during your analysis.
For example,
If we want to count customers, but
some of these customers are represented
in duplicate records, then we'll
need to fix this before counting them
up, or we'll get an inaccurate count.
As we start digging into data, we may
come across many forms of dirty data.
Think about the way that data
is captured by companies.
Some of it is entered manually, and
some part of that data will always be
suspect because of, well, human error.
Let's look at a few
examples of dirty data.
How many times has your name
been spelled wrong on a piece of
mail you've received?
That was probably caused by a typo when
someone manually entered your name.
How about when you get two
pieces of the same junk mail?
That's a problem with duplicate
records for the same person.
What about when you get a piece of mail
addressed to someone who used to live at
your address?
Well that's also a form of dirty data,
because it's not accurate, and
that person has moved on.